I'm about to help a complete stranger
build a $15 million per year business.
I'm going to give him a step-by-step
roadmap on exactly what he needs to do.
And 90 days later, we're going to check
in with him to see what actually
happened. If all the business owners
watching, I've scaled 10 businesses past
10 million, three past 100 million, and
I've realized an important lesson, which
is that businesses behave in patterns at
all levels. And so, you can take any of
the principles and tactics and apply
them to your specific business and
industry at its current size. There are
far more similarities than there are
differences. And so, with that being
said, let's meet Hussle.
>> Alex, how are you?
>> Ready to rock.
>> Yes, sir.
So, my name is Hussle Nazir. I'm CEO of
Smile Magic Dentistry. We are a holistic
dental practice that focuses on helping
prom- prominently women
>> Mhm.
>> achieve their
>> deserve nice teeth?
>> Usually the women are the ones doing the
research. The men follow after. Welcome
[music] to Smile Magic Dentistry.
>> So, give me the dollars.
>> Yeah, so these are some of our numbers.
So, our past 12-month revenue is around
$2 million. Our profit is right around
47% about 960,000. And our goal over the
next 3 years is to have $15 million in
revenue and about $5 million in profit.
>> Has the goal always been to do that, or
has the goal suddenly changed?
>> So, I've only joined the business about
a year ago.
>> All right.
>> So, previously my dad, he was the owner
of the practice. He didn't have the
support system to actually grow the
practice. So, he was essentially just
making ends meet doing what he can,
working as much as he can. With me
joining, it's been a matter of how can
we scale and I've kind of tried to
expand his horizons cuz I'm not a
dentist.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm purely focusing on the business
and just growing the business.
>> So, but is he
aligned with that goal?
>> Yes.
>> it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, what's stopping the scaling
right now?
>> So, right now we have three locations,
but one doctor. So, our staff, as well
as myself, are essentially shuffling
between location. So, all the
high-ticket patients are all flowing
through one person. The minute our main
doctor, my dad, takes a break, business
takes a break.
>> Do you have
other associates at all?
>> So, we had an associate over the past
year or so. He's actually leaving to go
to a master's program.
But, with him, the problem was we
weren't able to actually fill a
schedule. So, a lot of the time he was
only working about a day, a day and a
half per week. And for some reason, his
show rate would be a lot lower than my
dad's. So, why is solving this important
right now?
>> I mean, my dad has given everything to
the business. When I was a kid, he
wouldn't be able to show up for soccer
games essentially because the business
needed him in it at all times. So, with
him getting older and me joining and
seeing his past 30 years of hard work,
if we're unable to actually fix this
problem, it becomes a thing that will
just die. Our business will will die if
we're unable to solve this issue.
>> Got it. This will be really straight
down the middle.
This is good news. I mean, complex
doesn't mean good.
>> [laughter]
>> So, yeah, let's come over here. I'll
I'll walk you through what we have to
do.
>> [music]
>> All right. So,
the big issue is that right now you have
your dad who's doing all the diagnosis
of the people who are coming in. And
then he also does the actual implant
work. From a time perspective, does it
take longer to sell or take longer to
deliver?
>> Longer to deliver, I think.
>> Okay.
So, of the elements of delivery,
how many how many visits are is required
to do the treatment?
>> It would be approximately of actual
clinical work, about five visits.
>> Okay. So, it's five visits.
Of all those five visits, does your dad
need to do all five?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, does he currently do all five?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, of those
So, let's say we've got we've got sale,
right? Which I'll get to in a second.
So, we have the sale the sales motion
and then we have call it visit one, you
know, two, three, four, five. Okay,
which of these can he not do?
>> Depending on how complex like the actual
pulling of the teeth are,
that's really where some of our
associates have gotten hung up.
>> All right.
>> So, potentially he wouldn't need to do
visit five.
>> Okay.
>> So, we cannot search that.
>> All right. Visit five.
>> And then
>> Where does he pull the teeth?
>> It'd be visit one.
>> Okay. So, he he this one's a an
important one. Okay. So, he has to do
that one. What else? So, the rest of
these are
>> Visit two, he
pretty much needs to needs to do it.
That'd be like the bone graft. So,
essentially laying the foundation
>> Okay.
>> for the implant.
>> I'm not going to push back, but let's
just we'll keep going. Okay.
>> And then
visit three is a checkup, so
>> So, he doesn't have to be there?
>> Okay.
>> And then visit four is implant
placement, which I would say is
less important than the bone graft, but
very important. So, I would still I
would still say he needs to do
>> Let's say you just had an associate
level person. Is there any reason the
associate couldn't do these ones?
>> The only reason why they wouldn't be
able to do those three would be just
based on their clinical ability.
>> Well, this is a checkup.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> They can do that no matter what. Yeah.
>> that's probably some sort of last
conversation and also checkup. Okay.
So,
this one is a very basic thing, right?
Just implanting is the bone graft is
pulling in the graft is harder than the
than implant.
>> Correct. At times, yeah.
>> Okay. So,
I mean, wouldn't associate They are
doctors, correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, wouldn't associate be able to
just learn how to do the implant?
>> Definitely.
>> Would the guy that you had be able to
have that skill if that was like a
priority to teach him how to do this one
thing?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. So, let's assume that we can
actually get that off of his plate
because right now your cap that was it
like 25-ish
a month, I think.
>> About 25, yeah. About 25 to 30 patients
a month.
>> So, that's that's a huge point of
leverage. It's the greatest point of
leverage. So, if we just cut his There's
six visits to make this money. Three of
them are the most important that require
the most skill. The other three, not so
much. It's like that can take us from 25
visits a month to 50 visits a month,
provided we can increase the lead flow,
which we'll get to in a second.
But, do you think that that would be
like your dad would be on board with
that?
>> I think he would be on board with it.
The only
pushback I would ever say is more about
the patient journey.
>> Sure.
>> So, I think that a lot of the time
patients get very like connected to the
doctor, and I think having the handoff
has been the hardest part, especially
after doing some pretty like intense
visits. They have a hard time trusting a
different doctor.
>> That's not impossible.
>> Yeah.
>> It's Yeah, of course it's not
impossible. There's dental clinics that
have many doctors. Of course it's not
impossible.
Um but, that just sounds like what I
would consider to be a uh just a
limiting belief. Yeah. So, all he has to
do is just have a
um like he could film one time a video
that's that's with the doctor that he's
edifying. He says, "Hey, you know, this
is Johnny. Johnny's awesome. And so,
Johnny actually specializes in the next
three visits that you're going to be
coming out with us. And so, this is
literally all he does. And so, he's
going to take care of you for X, Y, and
Z.
Um and so, we've already laid a amazing
foundation. You've been healing great.
And that's what like the the road map
is. And so, if you have any questions,
you know, you can give Johnny a call.
He'll be, you know, available to you.
And uh yeah, so next time you see it, uh
you're not in the wrong place." Like,
"Ha ha ha." That's it.
>> Got it.
>> And you can obviously set that
expectation here. It's like, "Hey,
you're the the work is split between two
of us. One is One we specialize I
specialize on this side, he specializes
on that side. And that's it."
That's like That's totally mental,
though. He's obviously been a sole
practitioner for a really long time. And
it's one of those things where like
uh a lot of entrepreneurs feel like
it's nice to feel needed, and it's nice
to feel special.
>> Yeah.
>> But, there are other humans who have
hands who can learn things.
>> 100%.
>> Right. And it's like, okay, do you want
to be right or do you want to be rich?
And this is one of those scenarios.
>> And I'll tell you what he has to do like
what you have to convince him obviously
just that he has to be positioned as the
architect or the artist. Um and then the
other guys are the hands, and that way
it'll kind of preserve his
I won't say ego, but like it's like
you're still the puppeteer. You're still
the you know, you're the conductor of
the orchestra. Um and then from a from a
positioning perspective, that's what you
would say to the patients. It's like the
actual the hardest part is designing the
the procedure and the process. Um once
the plan's laid out, it's really just
executing it.
>> Got it.
>> Um and so that's that's easy to
position. All right. So, that's thing
one. This double This gives of a gives
us a double in capacity.
Now, that guy was quitting, but if he
was able to take all these appointments
on, would that fill up his calendar?
>> For the most part.
>> Okay. Well, I mean, in my mind, I would
say like maybe don't fire him if he was
a decent guy.
Um because that would double the
potential revenue of the business and
take you from two to four.
>> That feels worth it.
>> Yeah.
>> And you can make up the extra two
million in whatever you're paying the
associate.
>> Definitely.
>> Okay.
Okay. That feels That feels not not
dumb.
>> Hey Alex, it's been 90 days since I saw
you last, and here's an update about
what's going on and how things are going
inside the practice. I hired two
associates. They took off all of the
less complicated work from my dad, and
it's allowed us to do more consults,
and we're still able to fulfill the
patients' needs when they need it, and
schedule them closer to events. So, the
trade-off between doctors has been much
easier because we're framing my dad as
the architect, and we're framing our
offices as a team of doctors, not just
him. So, when we tell them they're
getting taken care of by another doctor
for some other treatment, patients are a
lot easier and a lot happier to do so,
and it's made the transition much
faster.
>> And so, the fact that you got two
associates on in such a short period of
time, and it's
you know, kudos to him for actually just
following following the steps and doing
doing what we all did. Okay, the next
thing is
when So, right now you have Google Ads
that are working, obviously, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I would just actually continue to
encourage you to just keep increasing
Google Ad spend.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz right now you're spending What are
you spending a month? Like 14,000 like
that?
>> 12,000, yeah.
>> 12,000, right? So, if you have $12,000 a
month, like you're not in you're in
Orange County.
Like you could probably go to several
hundred dollars a month before you even
get close to capping that area. So, like
there's a lot of runway there. But if we
double it, we can double the capacity,
we double the spend. Now, number three
is that you have like or your dad has
like a 85 or 90% close some very high
close rate.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I would do a couple things. So,
number one, when I see those kinds of
close rates, I would increase price.
Because
with those kind of close rates,
there's a probably a lot of room there.
What payment options do you provide
people?
>> So, it depends on what they qualify for.
So, either with an implant patient or a
long treatment plan, they pay as they
go. So, they would pay over the course
of a year.
>> Mhm.
>> Whenever they get the work done, they
pay for that that visit, essentially. If
they choose financing, they pay the
entire treatment up front.
>> Mhm.
>> And that's it.
>> What percentage of people do financing?
>> Approximately
maybe 30% of the treatment plans over
15,000.
30 to 50% on say.
>> I feel like you could get like 80 or
90%.
Like doing that. Cuz like my position
would be like, "Hey, so there's two ways
to pay. You can either pay on your
credit card and pay whatever you want,
or you can pay using financing, but
either way we need to pay now to get
this whole started.
>> Okay, so you would change it to a pay
now
>> I prefer that, especially from a cash
conversion cycle perspective. And that's
not that uncommon.
>> Do you think that it would be wise to
give them almost like a discount to
prepay? Cuz the way I mean, obviously,
it's more of a limiting belief, but the
way we've always done it is pay as you
go per visit.
>> No, I mean, I would I would be like,
"Huh, okay, I guess we could do that."
You know what I mean? Like, I would make
it seem odd.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Um but yeah, you can give the incentive,
um if you want, but it's like what this
is what most people do. Cuz you're going
to pay it either way cuz like believe
me, you can't half finish your mouth. So
like, you're going to have to end up
paying it, so you might as well just
prepay. Um and that's the way because it
allows us to pre-order some of the
things that we need um for your specific
case.
>> Got it.
>> That's how I'd script it. So I would
just say like, "A B
credit card  financing
and then you downsell
a payment plan."
Does that make sense?
>> Okay. We shifted our payment collection
process to paying per visit to paying up
front and it has been the biggest unlock
for us when actually growing and our
revenue have gone up substantially.
We've gone from averaging 160,000
a month
to
almost
we're on track to hit 500k. It is
unreal. I never thought it would happen
this quickly.
>> Well, I did.
Um
That's really awesome. That um
that
that makes me feel good.
Now, from a pricing perspective um
you're charging 14
is the average three-year value of these
implants?
Cuz that seems low.
>> It is low. So the three-year value of
implants is a lot higher. 14,000 is our
overall including patient recall.
>> Got it.
>> So, with implant patients, our average
our average ticket is around 28,000.
>> And is close rate is still 80 whatever
percent?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I mean
>> This is after we increased prices, too.
First thing I did following your
following your judgment
>> nothing happened, right?
>> Increased prices by 15 to 20%.
>> Mhm.
>> Originally, it was whole world is going
to end.
>> Yeah.
>> And then oh my and nothing happened. We
and I ended up trying to give more value
>> Mhm.
>> to patients and close rate increased.
>> Yeah, because it's a luxury item.
I mean, people
rather technically it's a premium item,
but I think I would go to 35k.
>> Okay.
>> And how long had it been since your dad
had raised his prices when you got him
to raise his prices?
>> Three to four years.
>> Yeah, and the thing is is that in that
time period, like the money supply went
up by a lot more than 20%.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
uh like
that change was not even that was like
still just make that was just
right-sizing. It wasn't even really a
price increase. That was just
right-sizing. So, I think given your
dad's experience and the fact that he's
closing 85 whatever plus percent, um I
doubt you're going to lose a lot,
especially because of the nature of how
you're having people pay.
It's because the actual monthly
difference is going to be negligible,
but it'll be a material difference for
you guys.
>> Definitely.
>> Extra 7,000 per scan will add up,
especially if you can pull it up front.
>> Okay. When we increased prices, our
average treatment plan was 28,000.
We increased prices 20% and our average
treatment plan is now 44,000
for implant cases. And
>> It's pure profit.
>> I thought patients would be hesitant,
but our close rate has
gone up about three to four percent, I
would say.
And patients are happy to be in an
office where we spend time and we
explain things and we're giving more
value, to be honest. And since we are
charging more,
we are over-delivering
on the service. We are giving them the
best experience they could ever have and
patients have never been happier, to be
honest.
>> He's now entering into the virtuous
cycle of pricing, which is that the more
you charge, the better the customer you
attract, the more you can over-deliver
for them, the more profit you make, the
better the talent you can bring on, the
more you can over-deliver, and so it's a
virtuous cycle of going up market rather
than competing down. A lot of goods,
especially if you're selling premium,
are Veblen goods, which basically means
that when the price goes up, um demand
also goes up, and health-related things,
specifically cosmetic, often has that
relationship. So, it's like, do you want
to go to the $50 tattoo parlor? No. Um
and so, if you have the money, you
typically want to spend the money for
the best person because you want to
massively pay down your risk because,
you know, getting your face messed up
for a nose job or, you know, whatever is
going to be so much
higher stakes than spending a little bit
more money. And so, I think a lot of
businesses are in the position where
they're actually selling around that
specific thing, but they don't realize
it, and so they're leaving a huge amount
of pricing power on the table, but also
just the additional cash flow to provide
a significantly better experience. So,
he went from closing fewer people at a
lower price with lower gross margin that
he could deliver less to
uh then have to compete with other
people with less margin to now selling
more people at a higher margin you can
over-deliver and continue to reinforce
the brand and bring on these other docs,
and this is like this is how you scale.
Another quick quick little thing is that
walk me through the sales process really
quickly
because to help support this price
increase, I just want to tweak sales
motion if we can.
>> Okay.
>> So, someone clicks, they schedule
uh you know, they call in or whatever,
they schedule their appointment, okay?
Walk me through what happens after like
from the time they schedule till the
time they give you money.
>> So, they schedule, they receive a
reminder 7 days before their
appointment, they receive a second
reminder 3 days, one last one day
before, one day of.
>> So, the 7 3 2 1.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> And then they show for their
appointment, and that is their initial
consultation. No work gets done. It's
purely potentially x-rays and a
>> right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, visual consult. And
>> Well, let's actually walk through that
in more detail. So, when they actually
walk in the door, what happens?
>> They walk in the door, we greet them,
and they get seated in the chair
immediately.
>> Okay.
>> Once we take the x-ray or the CT scan,
they come back to the chair.
>> Okay.
>> And it takes anywhere from 2 to 4
minutes.
>> Got it.
>> So, they sit back in the chair, we pull
up the scan with them, and we
essentially diagnose what they can't see
or what we can't see visually.
>> Mhm. So, you actually get the patient,
you say your teeth are up. Got
it. Uh when does it transition to okay,
give us money?
>> So, that transition doesn't happen in
the chair. That happens once he
diagnoses and things are complete, they
will either sit down with myself or
office manager, and we will
>> And that's they get out of the chair and
they go somewhere else into like a sales
room.
>> For an office.
>> Yeah, yeah. Okay, got it. So, every So,
two things that we need to I would tweak
is number one and this will help you
out, but I would put I'd grab everyone's
ID on the way in.
>> Okay.
>> So, I could scan it and then confirm
identity. Plus, I would swap that for
their credit card and say, "Hey, it's
just how we complete our patient
profiles." And that way you already have
payment method before you even ask for
payment.
Much easier way to do it.
Then, you're going to go to chair,
rigamarole, x-rays, etc.
Then, afterwards, they're meeting with
you, right? You have your your
one-on-one with them in office.
All right, in the front office or
whatever, right? Um
before they actually sit down. So, this
you have your x-ray here,
right? And then there's this period
where they come into this office.
>> Okay.
>> This is where before they actually sit
down with you, you should have them
watch a little VSL.
Little video sales letter.
And so, maybe you have them wait in that
office for like 5 minutes, 10 minutes.
And while they're there, you just give
them this iPad, "Hey, be right with you.
Watch this. That'll give you a little
bit more context on what the doctor just
shared with you." And then it's just
like basically a ton of testimonials.
Um
this
I'll give you the the the TLDR. You can
the recording. But, um
promise of the video like, "Hey, in this
video I'm going to show you how we
transform people's mouths. Um pain that
you're avoiding, which is like and so if
you have them in sure you've had pain or
you're like you're not confident with
your smile, you know these pains better
than I do. Um
our process will help you fix that. And
here's proof number one, proof number
two, proof number three, which are three
or four for different avatars. And so
that's what we'll walk through is kind
of like our our four-step process in
this video. So, then we go to big idea
number one, which is like the old way of
doing things is like this. The new way
our way of doing it is like this and
this is the core reason that we started
this practice and why so many people
have bad teeth and why our, you know,
patients are so happy. Um and that's the
core that's the core big idea.
>> Okay.
>> And then you just have what are the what
are the common objections that people
bring up in that sales consult?
Which is like some people have some
questions we like to cover them ahead of
time, which is, "Hey, you know, um
does this work for tiny teeth?" I don't
know, whatever. Like you know, like
you'll know you know what the objections
are.
Um and then with each of them you'll
follow through with uh this is what
people think, this is uh what's wrong
why it's wrong, this is what is true,
and then here's proof.
>> Okay.
>> And for each one of them it's basically
a simple objection overcome for each of
them. And then after that it's just
proof of just basically before and after
and people saying, "Oh my god, this is
amazing."
>> Okay.
>> And then what that'll do is because if
we're going to have an increase in
price, I want to give you more tailwind
to do it.
>> Okay.
And would you recommend going over
pricing the VSL as well? Like going over
>> you can do a range. You can do a range.
It depends on the number of teeth and
and whatnot. But our range can go from
here to here. But you have you already
have good close rates, so I don't want
to mess with too much. But like you
basically never sell less with a VSL.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you have already a a form of
payment on file, it's easier to do you
want to use the card on file? It's just
very easy.
>> Yeah.
>> And so to like you don't have to take
out the wallet again. It just decreases
friction, makes it very buttery.
>> Nice.
>> That make sense?
>> Very nice. I add in VSLs. Every patient
gets the VSL when they book an
appointment and then we show them a VSL
while they're waiting for me to present
the treatment plan.
It's made the process much more smooth
because we frame it as the biggest
investment they'll ever make in their
life when it comes to their health.
Patients know exactly what to expect and
they have less questions, so it makes
the process a little bit faster, in my
opinion. And
I've really there's been no downside.
It's only helped, to be honest.
>> So you have two levers in a sales
motion. You've got qualification and
education. Qualification is to make sure
the right people are showing up.
Education is to make sure they're in the
right mindset of showing up as in the
highest likelihood of of being willing
to purchase. And so if you have sales
processes that take too many calls or
take too long or there's too many
questions,
usually you need to educate more ahead
of time. Now the downside of educating
customers or prospects is that you're
going to lose people because not all the
people make it through, but there are
plenty of motions, especially in person
selling environment like the one that
Hassie is in, that you you're not going
to lose anyone. They're already at the
office and so there is absolutely no
downside to simply educating your
prospects more prior to asking them to
buy. Like there's just there's no
downside. You literally just make more
money, sell more people, they're more
convicted, you have fewer conversations,
the conversations are shorter, they buy
faster, they prepay more. It's all
upside.
>> Big picture, you have like what I would
consider be a very like straight down
the middle, which is like you're supply
constrained, this doubles our capacity,
long term we need to take up one and two
and give that to another doc as well. So
your dad can just focus on the
diagnosis. If you just do that, that can
get you to 12-ish million just from
doing that one change. And so you'll
have to break your dad's beliefs around
the fact that like what my father's a
physician, so like a surgeon and so I
understand the the archetype. There's a
lot of romanticism around like I have a
lot of repetitions on this and like no
one will be able to teach me or no one's
going to be as good as I am. I'm not
saying your dad's like like that, but
many surgeons are. And so
there has to be a fundamental belief
shift, which is that like if you learned
it, so can someone else and then
re-edifying him as like
you need like for for this business to
scale, his identity needs to change from
I'm the best dentist to I'm the best
teacher.
>> Yeah.
>> Like if you can make that change,
I think this thing can get really good.
If he if he holds onto the chair,
uh it'll be very difficult.
>> 100%.
>> Okay.
>> And with this, at what point do you
think it would make sense to possibly
buy new locations?
>> We need to
we need to fix all this stuff first.
>> Correct.
>> And right now, there's no point in
adding another practice cuz you don't
even know how to run a practice without
your dad.
>> 100%.
>> Right. So, it's like that has to happen
before any of these other conversations
can really occur.
>> When it comes to scaling, I thought we
would have to open three or four more
offices to really hit
five or 10 million dollars, to be
honest. But
with how we've been able to scale in the
past 90 days, we might hit our goal
without opening any new offices. I
think, like you said,
my dad is a teacher, so we need to frame
him as a teacher and actually teach.
If we can teach our doctors to do better
work at a higher level,
I don't see it being a problem, and I
think it'll unlock
maybe 3x, possibly 3 to 4x.
>> And so, this is the the quintessential
nail it before you scale it. A lot of
people think they need to scale to make
more money, but usually you need to nail
it to make more money, and then you make
so much money that you don't know what
to do with the money, and that is when
you scale. It's I think it's one of the
big, especially brick and mortar, the
big misconceptions. They're not making
as much as they want, so they're like, I
guess I should have more locations, when
almost always you should make the
location that you have significantly
better and more profitable. Like, I
cannot It's probably one of the more
mistakes that gets made in brick and
mortar. So, yeah, kudos to him for
actually just following through the
steps. And yeah, when you have, you
know, in the business probably good, we
can look at capacity for the office
space, but like
as long as demand gen is not a problem
locally, which I doubt it is, um he
might be able to get that location to
10, maybe even 15. And then we look at,
okay, maybe if we had three offices,
then we can go to 45 million, which
becomes much more interesting. Um
instead of having three offices to get
to 10. And so, uh yeah, kudos to
Husey for uh following the following the
steps and actually just executing.
>> That said, I'll just add a little bit of
a tidbit for these guys because you're
just getting into it. Um
but the speed to lead is especially with
Are you doing PPC?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um
it it is the most important platform for
speed to lead.
>> Yeah.
>> Like talking like 60 seconds because you
have super high intent people, but
they're shopping. They're looking around
and so it's most of the time, I don't
know the stat, but it's very high. Um
the first person who responds is the
person who gets the gets the customer.
>> Yeah. That's the one thing that I've
been focusing on.
>> Yeah.
>> This is killing you cuz a big part is
like he's booked out 15 to 30 days in
order for him to do these diagnoses,
right? And you're losing money there.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Perfect world would be this.
Like perfectly efficient world that I
think will maintain sales uh percentages
is that um they come in, greeted,
whatever, and then when they when they
walk into me with you, if possible, if
he says
"This is my guy. He's the man." He just
transfers authority. Says, "He's seen
more of these cases than anyone. Like he
will definitely help you out. I'll be
with you as soon as we get into the DEXA
rays." He just needs to do that. Just
edifies you and then you'll have the
whole frame. Then he'll come in,
razzle-dazzle, and then you close.
>> Got it.
>> Cuz in that way, cuz if he can just
basically the only time How long is the
DEXA rays diagnosis part?
>> 1 hour 15 We we book out
>> Right. Yeah. That's terrible. And so,
that's why it's taking 15 to 30 days cuz
like you have 70% rates, you'll probably
get closer to 85 or 90.
>> Mhm.
>> Um if that's the case, that would give
you a a 20% lift in revenue
>> Okay.
>> and return on ad spend just from that
one change.
Because you'll just move you'll just
pull it forward. Because then it's like,
"Great. We can get you in tomorrow." Cuz
they're they're literally they have
pain.
>> Exactly. 100%
>> we they want you to solve the pain. Um
and if somebody else can see them
tomorrow, they'll see them and not you.
Especially for a customer that's not
warm or referral.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? So, I see this as super material.
>> By hiring doctors and allowing them to
take care of the easier, less
complicated work, we've been able to
have our new patients booked within 7
days. Our close rate has gone up because
patients are seeing us sooner while
they're still in pain, and our show up
rate has made a big difference. It It's
only about 10% higher, but 10% with the
amount of patients we're seeing is a
huge difference and a huge unlock when a
patient's really in pain, they're coming
to see us, and we're getting them in as
soon as possible, and we finally have
the space to actually get them in.
>> Speed is almost always like if you add
speed to any sales process, sales will
almost always go up and profitability
will almost always go up. Just period.
If you have more availability where more
people can come in and you have almost
similar cost basis, you will just drop
incrementally more money to the bottom
line just by doing things faster. So,
you have fewer competitors who compete
for the same business.
People are willing to pay premiums for
speed. Um they will show up more often,
pay more, like every CAC reduces as in
your cost of getting customers goes
down, close rates go up, like everything
across the board is improved with speed.
And so, if you were somebody who's got a
business that has customers that are
coming at a delay, or they have to book
multiple weeks out, like you are
significantly exposing yourself to
competitors who are faster, and it's
better to put yourself your old business
out of business and then have your new
business than have somebody else do it.
Other than that, the business already
runs really good margins. The rest of
this is fine.
Um
but this would be the This would be the
next steps.
>> Got it.
>> Again, when I see
prices went up, close rates went up,
what that means is that, especially in
the market you're at, and for the when I
see market, I mean the geographic
market, but also the avatar itself, the
people who are walking in the door, they
they are
correlating price
with risk and quality.
And so, they're like, I this is this is
a complex procedure.
I'm going to use my mouth the rest of my
life. I want to make sure it's done
right. And for that person, an extra,
call it, $100 a month is going to mean
absolutely makes me no difference
whatsoever.
But them getting an inferior
uh procedure is going to make a huge
difference.
>> Huge difference.
>> You raised price and conversion went up.
>> Yeah.
>> So, keep raising price.
>> [laughter]
>> At what point do we know that we should
stop raising price?
>> Well, when conversion times price goes
down.
>> Okay.
>> Not when you sell less, cuz sometimes
you will sell less, but if you have a
50% price raise and you sell 10% fewer,
you should continue to keep that price,
right?
>> We're at a plus.
>> Right, exactly. You're at a You're at a
a plus plus. You're closing more at a
higher price.
>> Yeah.
>> There's going to be a point where you
close the same at a higher price, and
that's still good, and there's a point
where even after the curve, you close
even at a higher price with even a
little bit less than the and the math
still makes sense, but it's just a pure
math equation. I also understand the
nature of high-ticket sales like this,
which is very difficult to get. You
know, maybe he's having a bad day,
whatever happens.
Um
but I think you're very safe to continue
to raise for a minute. This is just like
probably the first of maybe another one
after this.
>> Got it. And then the one thing I was
going to start doing is just doing like
organic content.
>> That reminds me. I was going to bring
that up to bring it up to you.
So, what I want you to also do
is re-engineer the process.
I'm sure there's these reaction moments
when they get to see their teeth and
like they'll look bad, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, we just want to have this big
mirror
in your hallway
where you can have people kind of walk
up blindfolded or like not see it or
just you want to basically capture the
reveal moment. And you will probably
already do capture the before moment,
I'm guessing.
>> A lot of the time we don't.
>> Okay. Well, that needs to get integrated
in the process, right? Um
and so that becomes your posting. Like
every single before and after that you
have
at your clinic
should get posted, but you can have
multiple versions of this.
So, think about one is like the uh story
version, which is like um Um, Angela
showing her before and then showing her
after, and it's like, yay. And then
there's the uh carousel version, which
is like images that you might still put
the story as the third third tile that
you'd post. Um, you can do a case study
version of this, which is like your dad
or you reviewing the case. So, this is
Casey, she came in with an ex you know,
XYZ micro underbite. I'm making it up.
Right? Um, and so this was an
interesting case for XYZ. And so and
then but it's but then you're
immediately flipping it to like, so if
you're struggling with this this and
this and this, you don't have to
struggle with that. Like these are super
solvable problems. All people just don't
know it. That's why I'm making this
content.
And then with all of that stuff, you can
just CTA to lead gen.
>> Okay.
>> I didn't want to add a separate channel
because like this is the you're already
doing this. Let's just do more better on
this.
Um,
but as you like basically if you were to
come back, I'd like in a year, I would
say like, okay, this is going to be our
further expansion. And so what's
difficult with small businesses, there's
whenever you have a pipeline, if you as
long as you're not supply constrained,
which you are.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh, more marketing on a supply
constrained does nothing.
>> Yeah.
>> It does not increase throughput. And so
it's like we have to solve the supply
constraint first.
And then the other other things out of
the pipeline can increase and then that
increases throughput. But we have to
solve that first and then this alone
will match your throughput. So, could we
do it? Yeah. Is it a constraint? No.
Will it take resources from you to think
about? Yes. If you do all this stuff and
you have bandwidth, sure.
>> Got it.
Got it. The reason I was at least
thinking about it
>> Yeah.
>> was
>> I'm never going to tell you to advertise
less.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Small businesses like more people know
about yourself, the more more money you
make. Sure. Unless you have no way to
actually capitalize on it.
Yes.
Okay. How many employees you guys got?
>> Nine, including me.
>> Nine. All right. So, where are we at on
the scaling roadmap? So, you are
you're right at the kind of prioritize
to productize stage. Notice what we were
doing is prioritizing the things you
need to do and trying to develop
productization of the actual delivery.
It's almost like these things make
sense.
Um
And so
um you do have a specialized product
that's priced to serve a richer richer
after. So you already have this, which
is why I like from a business
perspective you're probably closer to
here. From a marketing angle, free more
free better stuff. Um
that's [clears throat] where this part
that I was referencing would kind of
come in and that will kind of graduate
here. And so it's common for businesses
to be split between multiple stages at
for different kind of functions.
>> Yeah.
>> From a sales perspective, I think you
just started tracking these basic KPIs.
So like you have probably more along
this product size step. So spend more on
this down messaging and new offer.
>> Fair enough. [laughter]
>> Right? Create sales aids and materials.
Right? And the VSL sales aids, right?
Build a proper CS playbook to onboard
and train team to answer questions. So
that is partially like how can we get
the team to do some of these pieces and
then obviously like overtime they're
going to be taking over more of the
delivery.
>> Agree.
>> Understood.
Make sense? The fact that you're at this
stage to graduate?
>> Fair enough.
>> Cool.
>> Alex.
>> Yeah. And by the way, this is free. If
you're a business owner and you're like
what stage am I at? What should I do?
Download this. Each one of these comes
with like a 90 plus minute video that
breaks down in way more detail than I
just did in 10 seconds,
um what to do at each stage. So if you
want that, you can go grab it. I'm sure
the link somewhere.
>> Meeting Alex has been on my mind for a
little while now and I know with the
amount of value he's provided to me
inadvertently, not knowing me, just
providing content to the masses, he has
already changed my life without him
knowing it. I've told myself going into
this that
no matter what he says, I know for a
fact that I will come out on top because
it's the insight I've been wanting for
years.
And it's the insight I can only dream
of.
>> Well, sweet. So you shifted it sounded
like you shifted more to more payment up
front.
Raise the implant pricing. Speed delete
is solid. You held off on scaling to the
new location. Um, yeah. So, all in all,
what's what's revenue at now? Run rate?
>> On run rate, we are right at 3.3,
I believe.
>> Oh, hell yeah.
>> So, we're right at, I believe it's
270,000
a month. When I saw you last, I think
we're at at 2.8 run rate.
>> Okay, 2.8 2.8 to 3.3.
So, what's that?
So, that's a 7% lift in that.
>> Yeah, 7% a month for some. And from
averaging
160, our best month before this was
290,000.
And now we're about at 500,000.
I never thought it'd be possible with
the same team doing the same things
we're currently doing. Honestly, Alex,
thank you.
Thank you so much. I
I have a lot of gratitude for your team,
for you, for what everyone has been
doing. Just the advice you've been able
to give when it comes to fixing limiting
beliefs. I think that's been the biggest
thing. Unlocking
belief conviction in myself, in my team,
in my dad, and our doctors has been the
biggest unlock of what's possible. Why
not?
Why can't we is the question. How fast
can we do it?
We'll keep it going.
>> Yeah, nothing to add there. I mean, it
was all him. And so, uh, you know, the
kudos should go to him because a lot of
people, you know, watch YouTube videos,
they
they uh, read my books, but they don't
do anything about it. And so, I guess
one of the one one of the nice things
about this competition is that, um,
people have public stakes
>> [music]
>> around
around taking action. And, um,
I think someone else said this, they
said, "I've never worked so hard in my
life." And I find that really
interesting cuz it's like
this whole time you've been working for
you, but only now you want to work
harder.
>> [music]
>> And I'm trying to think like how can I
recreate that stimulus or that
those conditions for entrepreneurs so
that more people experience that. I
mean, in my weight loss business, you
know, we started running these
challenges and people lost more weight
than they'd ever lost in their lives,
but it's because we had this external,
you know, carrot that we would leave
there, which is that if they hit a
certain goal, they could get [music]
their money back as credit towards more
service. And um
it'd be be really interesting to figure
out a way to do that again for
entrepreneurs, but you can see what
happens when you have correct advice,
ruthlessly executed, you get big
results.
All right. And so, that was this episode
of Scale or Fail. Stay tuned for the
next one as they all compete for
$100,000 and a year of working on
scaling.